man I want to start with you because
about four years ago I was on this stage
with you and your friend John Krasinski
the two of you had co-written and
starred in promised land and my
understanding is that the germ of this
film comes from the two of you is that
true yeah John told had an idea about a
story about an uncle having to return
kind of to his hometown against his will
that he that he pitched me over dinner
and he knew I was looking for something
to direct so I really liked this idea
and I mean we really did not have much
at all
but but what we had we decided
immediately that Kenny would be our
favorite person to write it because he's
our favorite writer and so we we went
and pitched him this idea and he well
you guys don't really have a lot no but
like that scene you know and and then we
kind of we left it with Kenny and but
Kenny had a huge log jam of work and
other deadlines he had to hit four other
projects and so we were kind of at the
back of the line and and we went away
and in our own impatience kind of wrote
and produced and starred in promised
land and kind of forgot about this and
then Kenny came back around a couple
years later with with this draft that
was just beautiful but it was it was
long but everything that was in here was
in that draft and and that was when I
Chris Moore and I were on it on the
project and that was when we kind of
called each other and went oh my god
this is really special Kenny what about
the conversations that you had sparked
something in you what were you
interested in exploring from what they
talked about well I just really liked
the idea a lot I thought it was very
moving and interesting and the idea of
someone in that much trouble trying to
do something that big and coming up
against that big of an obstacle I
thought it was really interesting
Kimberly what about you what when you
first read it obviously I'm sure you
have people coming to you wanting help
wanting resources what caused you to
take a chance on this project um it was
really scripted then from there seeing
how much you know I got a chance to meet
Matt and then me Chris and seeing their
passionate behind the project and then
you know knowing that Casey Affleck or
somebody always wanted to work with it
just kind of all fell in line and we
were really you know wanting to get
behind her tours you know as our company
lunch so Kinney was a very special one
to start with so it feels really awesome
Lucas so many of us are discovering you
for the first time through the
performances Patrick which is so
terrific and so and brings such a great
ingredient my understanding is that of
the major cast members you were the last
in one of the last to come on board what
was the audition process like for you
and how excited did you allow yourself
to get as you continued the process yeah
so I auditioned five times I think six
times actually two for this movie and I
find that when I'm auditioning I III
often fantasize about what it would
obviously what it would be like to do
this movie and I picture what it would
be like to do these scenes and to like
to be if I mean it's kind of the dream
to like be a to be a part of a movie
with with these people like I with Casey
and Michelle and to like be a part of
this family and to to and so I found
myself fantasizing a lot over the course
of the auditioning process and then when
I got it it was like oh [ __ ] like okay
this isn't just a family I mean it is a
family but like there's actually like I
got a deuce I got to do something now
like I actually have to I got to produce
in the scenes that are just so intense
we're in a space of just a couple of
minutes your characters are going from
composed to the opposite of composed how
much time is necessary to reset before
you do it again well you don't have that
much time so you can't stand around and
say give me half an hour I'd like to
reset my countenance
and then Kenny's got his ideas of what
needs to be reset and changed and so
it's you which is good you know all of
those demands are always helpful no
matter how you they feel like
restrictions but they're usually things
that help you just not overthink things
ya know I mean I remember that that it
always when you're working on movies
that are this small there that goes so
quickly you never really have as much
time as you want but you've tend to
always have as much time as you need and
that day specifically maybe that last
scene is what you're talking about I
remember it kind of going by in a blur
it was like you know that was like one
of that was not the only scene to do
that day that was just one thing on that
day so there wasn't a lot of time in
between some effort was made to you know
press back your eyes and try and start
from the beginning but um no there
wasn't a lot of like space around it I'm
always intrigued Kenny by films that
portray family members and ones that do
it so well where the audience believes
wholeheartedly that these are people
that are with each other day in and day
out for decades how did you go about
trying to foster that family kind of
environment amongst your actors who did
play family members oh you know a lot of
its just staying out of the actors way
really because you know they come in
with so much and they have so many ideas
about who they are and what the
relationships are and and and there's
very respectful of the script and want
to call what's in the script and it's
always fun to look at actors scripts
when they're not looking because there's
all these notes like often anyway and
there's just that and just to hear them
start to talk about you just got a
little piece of everything that they put
into it so I I guess it's a question of
getting everyone oriented in the similar
way and just at least giving them my
version of the story and then having
that be a starting point my version plus
their version and then what happens when
they get in front of the camera is is
always a surprise and I'm almost always
a pleasant surprise and just there's a
five-year gap in the story and just
tracking specifically what happened in
those
five years and what didn't happen and so
you know when they get in the room
together they at least have the common
history to know and kind of you know the
kind of specifics that actors always
bring to the roles that it just astonish
you and you like oh my god he thought
about what he had to lunch that day and
he thought about like where he was when
he went yesterday and how many times
he's been there and you're like holy
[ __ ] he really worked this is a lot of
work but that's the results are that
they're really in the moment and in a
very very full way and that's seen
you're referring to indeed all the
scenes or that you know they just bring
this incredible I my recollection is it
was easy to reset because they're they
have so much they're carrying around
these these incredible burdens and so
all they have to do is see each other
and they start to just spill out of them
and it's amazing I mean it's one thing
to write that it's another thing to
embody it I don't know how they do it
well you guys all did a fantastic job
I congratulate this entire panel thank
you so much